yoth monde c'est squeeze aujourd'hui on
se retrouve sur un tout nouveau mode sur
gallas mode qui s'appelle escape
pedobear les règles sont très très
simple cinq secondes après le début de
chaque nouvelle manche il ya un pedobear
qui va paraître sur la map et tu vas
essayer de nous pourchasser et de nous
tuer le but du jeu est d'être le dernier
en vie parce que vous allez voir le
parcours est un peu compliqué hein oui
je sais que vous regardez que ça alors
je le cache et wim ce truc j'espère que
ça va vous plaire cordialement la
direction qui elle a changé de planque
rock le punk la vérité sur le plan
hockey les mecs aiment ça et qu'on peut
faire mais [ __ ] mais quoi mais la
douche froide
non mais ah mais non mais non ils faire
apparaître au milieu mais non mais non
elle chacun derrière la voilà du coup je
suis dernier il faut cracher comme un
souffle je sors ta présence
je sens sa présence chanter son duvet un
peu contre monde aux sur wii j'avais
confiance en toi dartin je croyais ali
pour toujours arrête de boire du vin
boutoir à nous deux très bien tu vas
bien croche-patte enquête
j'ai tendu ma grosse bande de lâches sur
la poutre dégage start 1 certains
accélèrent [ __ ] mais maintenant ça il
ya des psychiatres comme ça sur son
visage et il claque mais je propose que
pour ce round on prenait un petit peu
plus notre temps l'accord n'a pas le
temps on regarde les deux pieds dedans y
ait un beau mec elle est où marche aller
aux marches interdit de courir interdit
de courir mis ko des précédents mode bat
les couilles boeuf mika tu vas trop vite
et tu vas mieux à l'uppercut au passage
il y avait une côte raide chinoise dans
le dos
non il y avait un petit silence de la
concentration c'est magnifique apte à
mecha votre blague de chauves l'a pas
poussé un bâtard mais qu'il l'a fait six
ans fouad le cas tu vas courir 10 km
heure ici laboratoire vient d'affirmer
qu est ce que tu fais maintenant
pedobear de merde
certains étaient comme ça hein oui les
adieux hugo un coucou à l'eau à la
sortie du crash et aussi sa lubie cas
alors on est mort on me regarde pas
comme samica ayant le attention la mort
dans deux secondes est bonne à rien aux
questions au bate à lala com vous êtes
nuls
il forme un coeur quoi il a fait qu'il
est tombé de 20 mètres il a fait par un
doigt de renommée quoi bon les mecs
attention sur celle-là je réussir à
l'appareil voilà longtemps que vous
attendez attendez j'ai une technique
j'ai une technique peut-être atv toi il
faut de côté jardin si je me cache alors
je monte sur ton dos hugues au blizzard
ont gardé mon rythme il s'appelait
panique alors non il a fait un saut en
mode frites quoi je vais doubler tard
trois hommes gagnent 1 cm au petit matin
non mais je me rends reculant du 15 mai
week-end maintenant c'est parti je suis
un speedrun l'ex à chaque manche quoi la
technique du cm alors tagro dix huit y
meurent ici quoi le cm le cm le cm nom
propre à l'équipe de droite celle et
bien j'ai failli oui mais là tu es en
l'air avec moi le plat ou plat au blabla
cm mais ce nom ces bons centimètres
c'est parti c'est mon ressenti m mais
mon but était qu'il attend ça sans lui
ce qu'il à lattes et pas très fort oleg
barre toi bats toi oh [ __ ] extrême
plupart affichent le silence tellement
débordés moment il ya juste eu des
envies
as tu fait glisser là tu atterris
j'étais derrière toi tu as fait un petit
j'ai appelé ton tu ne t'en faire il
ferait sur tokyo les athlètes russes
n'ont fils de start up et deviendra
t'attraper certainement pas lui pas lui
jeter eu l'impression de ouf
lucas je te paye d'accord donc je me
prenne à moi je me fais insulter
gratuitement dans le jeu c'est chômage
tranquillement je vais acheter baguettes
de bouddha bourgi comme tous les matins
et je me prends un petit lucas je te
paye ouais les cas par contre c'est un
bon on va peut-être qu'on va être papa
ma chance noir et le grand plongeon dans
la foule en chef attention le fei de
vicat je découvre cette zone de la mode
qu'est ce qu'il y a des peaches de
l'argent au 15 août yeux de blanc et
qu'elle pousse à les dépouiller tous les
quatre au québec est peut-être ai-je
fait qu elle est juste sur mon moulin
tranquillement quand soudainement
d'insultés au n'ont put peut-être là
j'ai fait n'importe quoi google avait
jeté comme ça appuyez sur tes pour
passer ce moment bien chien ou jugon est
en train de jouer ttt à mettre du vide
et [ __ ] a battu martin vient du latin
je comprends bien tu me faire un geste
fort à tartas et temporise trois
secondes par cube à des jeunes qu'à meka
quel silence
mika sentent rassurés car j'étais partie
par la technique j'étais sur mon siège
de veille à le chien pied sur la touche
z de ton clavier s'est dit trahi et y en
a qu à lancer structure de feydeau
attendu qu'à nom de chien [ __ ] ejp
partie de mika
on y tient un média je croyais f k les
cas renégats jetez pas chercher un verre
de coca et voilà les gens c'est déjà la
fin de ce petit mode escape pedu bien
j'espère ça vous aura plu on se retrouve
très bientôt dans une nouvelle vidéo que
tout le monde